welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and there is something creepy going
on with the key lime pie in Loki season
two from close-ups of the pie slices
that are way too Green in this trailer
footage to this new footage from Loki's
partnership with Mickey D's
apple pie now here we are enjoying a
meal like Channel you slap me in the
face I'm not gonna get you a shake okay
yeah Moby is beelining for that
McDonald's apple pie aligns with some
disturbing things we've been noticing
about the role of pie in this upcoming
season of Loki It's oddly vibrant shade
of green despite real key lime pie being
more yellow in color and some super
specific rules and regulations governing
the pie that we've discovered in posters
for the series I believe this key lime
pie is the key Miss minutes in the king
Dynasty's new toxin to control the TVA
and if we really knew what it was made
out of your mouth wouldn't be watering
so much unless you were like Army Hammer
now sag after has informed us that
entertainment journalists like new rock
stars are allowed to continue covering
movies the way we do it but we join the
goal to the studios and streamers to
make a fair deal with the screenwriters
and the professional working actors now
you will notice in these McDonald's
promo shots that Loki greets Sylvia as
she works as a McDonald's employee with
a real McDonald's uniform from the 1970s
they share an odd connection a sense of
deja vu but is Sophie really looking at
Loki here or past his shoulder at Mobius
and his hunky prisoner Brad wolf played
by the hunky Rafael Casal who in this
series will be a hunky film actor
starring in a movie called zaniac now
zaniac and Brad Wolf come from the 80s
Thor Comics zaniac is a swarm of
parasitic creatures from the dark
dimension who possess a host and cause
him to feel overwhelming bloodlust and a
desire to kill women yeah it's a pretty
goofy storyline for the comics one that
the MCU now seems to be paying homage to
as a narrative within The Narrative of
the MCU but there may be some other
reason that Loki and Mobius need Brad
wolf he could be an actor with some
importance to history for some dishonest
forgery skill that Loki is now unable to
do himself as famously one of the MCU
characters who can shapeshift and
pretend to be other characters or maybe
70 Sylvie just has a huge crash on this
movie star by the way the music we're
hearing in this McDonald's promo is an
instrumental version of Moon River
famous from the 1961 Audrey Hepburn film
Breakfast at Tiffany's later recorded by
Andy Williams leading to one of my
favorite substance moments
how I didn't think he was gonna do Moon
River but then bam second Encore but
really it's mobius's eagerness to Chow
Down on some apple pie that I'm most
curious about would McDonald's really
agree to be featured in this if they
weren't the hero of the day somehow so
why do I think Loki season 2 is going to
come down to pie no it's not just
because time is circular in the series
and the ratio of pi is literally the
ratio of every circle circumference to
its diameter or in the case of Loki the
full length of the circular sacred
timeline divided by the longest distance
a time traveler on that secret timeline
would have to travel to time slip to the
furthest distance across that timeline
if I've already lost you I'm so sorry
this is supposed to be about food I know
I know okay so the posters that are
referred to concern a new setting in the
TVA that we did not see in season one
it's called the automat and we've seen
this automat throughout the trailer for
the season but among the posters that
have been released there are three green
ones one about bringing your own mug one
about busting your own table and one
ordering no more than one slice of pie
per week and I pointed out my my deep
dive of Loki season one The TBI overall
is color coded to show the hierarchy of
the organization orange at the bottom
level for security green at the middle
tier for the clerical level and then
gold for the top legal level so the
automat which is colored green is in the
same part of the TVA where the archives
were where people like Mobius work and
where in season one the cafeteria was
that was also colored green what's
interesting is we never saw this automat
in season one no one talked about key
lime pie in fact in that cafeteria in
season one The TBA employees were
allowed to eat anything they wanted
salad juice boxes whatever there seemed
to be a variety of food options now it's
just pie pie pie but we know that the
TVA has been warped somewhat since the
season one finale to alter those giant
timekeeper statues into one giant Kang
statue in the season 2 trailer there is
a shot that looks like it is right after
the events of season one where the
lights and the backdrop architecture of
the TVA are shutting off grid by grid we
may be seeing the process of the TVA
rebooting like a computer or a machine
or a clock and then turning back on with
certain updates and upgrades to the
employees of the TVA are programmed to
accept as having a always been there I
believe another customization will be
this automat with one intended purpose
to force feed TVA Employees new weekly
vitamins that they can't get enough of
to make it so that the anomaly that
occurred at the end of season 1 never
ever happens again a deserter a druid a
mutant and a tuck and Cyborg dog are
tasked with vanquishing an ancient demon
but they'll have to evade Monsters
Warlords cannibals in one angry
ex-girlfriend along the way that's the
premise of a cool new graphic novel
called the Codex that we are so excited
to partner with on their Kickstarter
campaign the 196 page Dark Fantasy Epic
from hayburner Studios is the first of
six planned volumes from writer Corey
crater and a team of talented artists
we've read an advanced copy of the first
volume and we love the mix of sci-fi and
Fantasies all set in a fully realized
post-apocalyptic world it's like if
George RR Martin wrote an X-Men Comics
set in the world of Mad Max it's got
some great dialogue beautiful art and a
great lived-in relationship between its
main characters all the pages already
completed and all the artists have been
paid so the kickstarter campaign is
really a way for you the interested
graphic novel readers in the new
Rockstar's audience to discover the work
so click the link in this video's
description to check out the kickstarter
and support the project let's look more
closely at these three posters each of
them in the bottom right read 17 minutes
is sufficient and one of them says
failure to bust your own table will
result in 31 demerits 17 31 both of them
prime numbers and numbers that are just
really really annoying to keep track of
and to quantify your routine in any
repeatable way they're designed
basically to screw with you and to make
your job Harder by the way again in
season one we never heard of any mention
of demerits of tokens this is stuff
coming from new memos that the TVA has
gotten and yes these posters are going
to be real props that we see in the show
like this poster about the cleaning of
the mugs does hang an automatic a shot
of Sylvie in the trailer shows a behind
her in the background another shot in
the trailer that I have to point out
shows Loki falling past another new
division of the TVA that we didn't know
about before called the timeline
preservation Administration last season
the TVA was depicted as a kind of
enforcement agency a legal Authority one
that had a sloppy waste management
process of just dumping all pruned items
to the void in my recent Miss Minutes
video I pointed to another poster and
shots in the trailer that indicated the
TVA is now being revealed as a kind of
power plant but rather than one that
uses Atomic or nuclear energy one that
uses temporal radiation emitted from a
temporal core you can read those terms
on the poster for the suit that Mobius
wears in the trailer as he approaches
this core the timeline preservation
Administration might be some entity in
the TVA tasked with maintaining and
recycling all materials that are used in
this process to reduce its temporal
carbon footprint so to speak this brings
me back the unsettling slice of key lime
pie that is fed to the TVA Employees
every week in the automat and its bright
shade of green food should not be this
color I think the most famous dystopian
sci-fi example here is a 1973 Charlton
Heston film Soylent Green based on the
1966 novel make room make room by Harry
Harrison in which future Society set in
the year 2022 deals with overpopulation
by feeding people a substance called
Soylent Green I'm gonna spoil it here
because it's been 50 freaking years and
it's a top 100 AFI quote Soylent Green
is people I believe that like nuclear
power pruning timelines in a temporal
fuel creates waste before that waste
could just be fed to Elias in the void
done and done flush it to nowhere but
now with Elias defeated and the void
defuncts there must be some other waste
management process and voila the pie fed
to the TDA Workforce like clockwork the
pie could contain Trace temporal fuel
memories of the screaming families and
the timelines that were burned out of
existence and this would leave TVA
Employees doped up with the right mix of
euphoria and anxiety to keep them on
task and to keep them from asking the
real questions like any pizza day at any
job the true purpose is to keep the
employees from rising up and eating
their bosses and that is why I think
McDonald's and their wonderful apple
pies are gonna be so important because
they're the one non-tva pie that can
open these people's eyes to the truth
after all what was Kang variant he who
remains eating when Loki and Sylvie met
him what fruit that is famously best for
baking apple pies a granny smith green
apple I rest my case
amen let me know your thoughts on this
horrifying Theory And subscribe to all
three channels in the new rockstars
Network you can follow me on all social
platforms at eat a bus thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
[Music]
thank you